all right and the san luis obispo  Tribune reports the California couple  recovered a wedding ring from the ashes  of their home and a second marriage  proposal took place the destructive  holiday fire erupted in Santa Barbara  last Friday and destroyed the home of  issue and Laura rau the couple returned  to the property and guess what  miraculously found Laura's scorched ring  issue dropped to his knees and asked  Laura to marry him again at the Santa  Barbara firefighter caught the whole  moment on camera it's nice because  they've only been married eight months  she said this was her prized possession  other than a guitar that belonged to her  late father so to find it in the ashes  that way and he proposed again it's nice  no oh it's lovely and they're like this  is going to last phoenix rising from it  there you go